and he'll now in today's world
anything's possible right right and I
wish we had somebody else in there who
is more elegant and eloquent and
sophisticated and oh yeah not right no
no I don't think anybody's gonna
challenge him from the Republican side
and on the Democratic side I think
they've got to get 18 to 20 you know
potential candidates in there and end up
beating their own and so it could be it
could be a real you know slugfest and
turn each other as they're trying to
establish someone who's a viable
candidate kind of like what the
Republicans did right yeah ended up with
you know we ended up with President
Trump and you know the Democrats if
they're not careful you can end up with
the same thing look they're talking
about Joe Biden
I told bitings an excellent cat right
150 years old hundred fifty years old
and he lost twice before yeah but
everybody loves the person that's on the
bench right until they get in the game
and so you know who knows where they
gonna go with that but you know could
they had this idea that they've got
compromising information on them here's
here's what I think is that if Muller
has figured this out right and he's been
quiet about it and they then the most
remarkable thing about this
investigation will be that nobody leaked
because you can't keep a secret in
Washington and so the fact that for two
years now we don't have like that that
that bullet you know that they think
they're going to come up with at some
point my inclination is to think that
you know Maul is gonna finish this
investigation issue some findings and
nobody's going to be happy because there
won't be a bullet and so the left won't
be happy the right won't be happy
because he'll still be pointing out the
fact that there was you know a lot of
you know stupid moves on the campaign's
part and that there was inappropriate
activity by you know people like manna
for it and others but do I think there's
gonna be some smoking gun I don't I
don't think so because and my reason for
saying that is because I've never known
Washington not be able to keep our two
to be able to keep a secret right this
is one like Mueller ever done one of
these things before though he seemed
uniquely calculated yeah he's done this
before and and he has he said look he's
a very smart guy and a very seasoned
operator investigator and he's got good
people working for him and it's
absolutely correct to let him go with
this and just let him finish it up right
but when is that gonna be who knows
right nobody had we have they've been
talking about oh he's gonna wrap it up
next week he's gonna wrap it up this
week he's gonna know he's not you know
he'll you know you think he's gonna wrap
it up who knows this could this
literally could go onto into it's gonna
have to end before probably end of this
year I don't think even he's gonna want
to for political calculations let it go
into too close to 2020 in the election
right so regardless even though I don't
think he's a big leap political
individual I think he's gonna see that
the wisdom of wrapping it up before then
and then letting the chips fall wherever
they do